pour nadine fuchs vice merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france
comment le corps médical allemand
accueille les mesures prises par berlin
mais très très bien parce que c'est le
bon sens même et je dois dire que
l'organisation de gestion des médecins
la cassonade session sa anigo a dès le
début de la première vague même
développer un maillage étroit de
d'endroits où vous pouvez faire des
tests corona d'endroits où on pouvait
aller en toute sécurité si on avait de
la fièvre et ces mesures ont été
réactivées actuellement maintenant que
les le nombre de cas augmente
malheureusement
comment situez l'allemagne
comparativement à la france justement
vous parlez d'une augmentation des cas
on a dit que la situation avait triplé
récemment annoncé que les hôpitaux
allemands possèdent plus de livres
l'animation les établissements français
oui c'est exact l'allemagne possède
posséder au début de la pandémie en mars
elle devrait avoir un peu pas dix neuf
mille lits doria disponibles
actuellement la capacité a été augmentée
on en dispose d'environ 30000 en tout
dont en ce moment 2665 sont libres c'est
c'est rassurant mais il ne faut pas
baisser la vigilance parce que tout peut
basculer très rapidement
enfin la transmission du virus si on ne
la contrôle pas elle est rapidement
exponentielle et je dois dire que en
allemagne on a
d'abord on a eu la chance entre
guillemets d'être contaminés après
l'italie et après la france en mars
donc on a eu le temps quand même de se
préparer c'est quatre semaines c'est
important et ensuite on a effectué de
nombreux tests et leur nombre a encore
augmenté
actuellement je crois qu'on en est à peu
près 1,7 million de tests par semaine
parce que on a testé tous les gens qui
revenaient de vacances quand sur
l'autoroute dans les aires de repos
d'autoroute il y avait des des des
endroits qui ont été construites toutes
pièces on pouvait faire des tests
qu'ovide de façon à connaître tout de
suite
à savoir tout de suite s'ils ont été
contaminés ou non
ça permet de repérer très très
rapidement les chaînes de contamination
et de les éviter
permettez moi de vous couper vous avez
évoqué une courbe exponentielle
en france il ya beaucoup de cacophonie
par rapport aux chiffres le gouvernement
qui se contredit les scientifiques
également par rapport par exemple le
professeur philippe juvin qui appelle à
commander des lits de réanimation
rapidement en france le professeur
toussaint qui lui parle de maladie sont
malades au final qui croire on a
l'impression que plus on avance moins on
en sait comment les populations semblent
perdus notamment en france c'est ce que
c'est le cas en allemagne comment la
population
le vix alors si vous voulez des chiffres
globaux en gros jusqu'à il ya deux jours
en france il ya eu à peu près 540 2600k
en allemagne 288 1631 le nombre de décès
en france est monté à 31 1808 et en
allemagne à 9 lui 468 et comment est ce
que vous expliquer cet écart alors alors
on a eu le temps d'anticiper je le dis
c'est pas anodin quatre semaines de
différence est beaucoup
ensuite on a tout de suite l'allemagne
est un pays fédéral ce qui fait que vous
l'avez vu d'ailleurs vous venez de
présenter un reportage où on voit angela
merkel la chancelière s'entretenir avec
les 16 ministres président et c'est les
décisions sont prises en consensus mais
une fois le consensus obtenu c'est le
ministre-président de chaque langue qui
décide les mesures appropriées dans son
land
parce que vous avez des situations très
disparates vous avez un ami
nord-westphalie qui actuellement à
beaucoup de cas alors que d'autres en
france par exemple ait des décisions qui
sont prises de manière locale on l'a vu
à marseille on le voit à paris et dans
certaines grandes villes avec des
restrictions pour les marnais
et bah oui oui oui mais je pense que à
l'époque
en allemagne on a fait des tests plus
tôt et là on l'est on a encore monté la
capacité du nombre de tests et on a le
résultat au bout d'un jour ce qui permet
de d'éliminer les chaînes de
transmission 100g millions quarantaine
est ce qu est la stratégie finalement
est meilleur en allemagne qu'en france
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous dites
j'ai pas dit ça ce serait prétentieux de
le prétendre
mais je dis que si vous voulez moi ce
qui me frappe c'est que ici du moins
dans la partie de l'allemagne où je vis
c'est à dire le bade wurtemberg les gens
respectent les consignes c'est à dire
dans les magasins porte toujours des
masques tiennent une distance de
sécurité avec les autres personnes la
plupart du temps il ya toujours des
exceptions bien entendu et puis sont
enfin sont relativement respectueux des
consignes alors évidemment vous avez vu
dans votre reportage que certaines
personnes quand elles vont au restaurant
ne donnent pas leur véritable adresse
etc
mais tout ça va être surveillés de
beaucoup plus près maintenant de façon à
pouvoir déterminer quels sont les gens
contagieux et quelles sont leurs sujets
contacts ça c'est primordial tant qu'on
a pas de traitement
merci nadine fuchs vice d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes médecin et que vous exercez donc en
allemagne